right great so next up i'm excited to
hear cindy rush talk about all or
nothing phase transitions
thanks alex um and thanks uh to the
organizers so um
okay so just uh for some quick
motivation so
uh we know in modern machine learning
and high dimensional statistics uh we
often face regression or classification
problems for example where uh the
dimension of the feature vector is often
much larger than the
effective underlying dimensionality of
the structure so
uh one example would be the imnes digits
uh each of which is represented by a
vector of 784 pixels but um
it's you know approximated that the
effective dimension is closer you know
to the or to the order of tens
another example would be you know
natural images tend to be sparse in a
wavelet basis for example
so um these uh and other developments
have justified a sort of better and
sparsity principle which uh in a
nutshell sort of says that uh the
intrinsic low dimensionality is often a
crucial ingredient in um interpreting
such high dimensional models
and so um for this reason uh in this
this sort of sparse context um what we
chose to study were some essential
scientific questions about establishing
fundamental benchmarks of problems um i
probably don't need to convince this
argument that this audience that uh you
know these are important um lines of
work but you know i'll say a few words
introducing uh these sorts of
fundamental benchmarks so what we wanted
to answer is you know
studying sparse problems what conditions
ensure that the information and the data
is sufficient for
satisfactory inference and what are the
most efficient algorithms for the task
so in other words we're looking for
information theoretic and computational
limits which analyze how much data is
needed for various problems um if we
want to perform the inference in a
computational
computationally efficient way or if we
just want to perform it um at all
and so um okay so what i'm gonna talk
about today uh in this talk is some
strategies for establishing these sorts
of limits um specifically in the case of
rank one matrix estimation from noisy
measurements
where we're in a setting that i'll call
a true sparsity regime where
the sparsity in our signal scales
sublinearly with the the problem
dimension
and so um oh pause to mention that
lowering matrix estimation of course is
uh an important problem and it has many
applications so for example image
processing pca or tensor decomposition
and while the mathematical analysis of
this problem is fairly well developed
most of the the study has been in the
the case of linear sparsity so when the
signal has a small but uh fixed fraction
of non-zeros as um
the the uh problem grows and so what
what i'm going to talk about today is is
some
uh strategies for for looking at these
sorts of statistical and computational
limits um when the the sparsity is
actually um vanishing as the problem
size grows
so um okay so here's the model that um i
i'm looking at so we have a signal x
uh that's a lengthen vector and i'm
assuming that the elements of the the
signal x
are um sampled iid according to some
distribution i've labeled x or sorry
i've labeled p
um and when defining p i want this to be
a sparse distribution so that
delta there is the direct delta at zero
and um
the number of non-zeros of my signal is
uh controlled by this parameter rho
which gives the the weights in this
distribution so in particular
we're we're in the sub linear sparsity
regime so i'm thinking that rho is going
to zero uh as n grows
um so uh for for this talk i'm going to
assume that this distribution p is a
bernoulli or um a bernoulli
uh rademacher distribution
and so um then the the problem becomes
uh okay one where we have access to a
noisy data matrix w and um we're
modeling
uh w as a sum of a spike term which is
the xx transpose based on our sparse
signal
and gaussian noise so the gaussian noise
is this matrix z
which is a symmetric iid gaussian matrix
and so in defining this model um i'm i'm
adding a parameter lambda there that
we'll see
must be growing but this is going to
control the the signal-to-noise ratio of
the problem and so then my goal is to
estimate um the spike xx transpose uh
given
my
my matrix w
and so um this is
this you know for example it's going to
build on the work that salil uh talked
about yesterday it's it's sort of the
same um the same sort of model
okay so um before i uh tell you about my
results i'll just mention some related
work uh that you know we've heard about
even um you know at this workshop so far
so uh there's been lots of work on
various forms of sparse spiked um models
um
and it turns out that these uh works
have played sort of a crucial role in
understanding threshold phenomenon and
problems uh more generally however many
of them um study this sort of
uh proportional sparsity regime and not
the sublinear sparsity regime that we
look at here
and kind of the picture that emerged
from these works um
is that uh you know the the information
theoretic and the statistical thresholds
um
actually uh you know happen in very
different uh sort of settings a very
different regimes and the gap between
these thresholds actually diverges as my
uh signal sparsity uh goes to zero
however um in many of these these works
even for the linear sparsity regime
um establishing these exact thresholds
with specific constants and um
you know characterizing the behaviors of
the mses that defined these thresholds
uh remains sort of uh elusive
and so um this kind of changed recently
so uh at first you know um
lucier and co-authors used heuristic
methods from statistical physics and
um
in particular the the replica method to
observe sharp um phase transitions and
many problem settings and then um the
rigorous mathematical uh theory
supporting these these characterizations
is now uh largely under control and so
um in the works i've i've related most
of the way that the people study
these these
uh phase transitions rigorously is
either through um
an approximate message passing algorithm
for the computational limits to tell
where the message passing algorithm
succeeds or fails um and then for the
statistical limits uh
folks usually characterize the
asymptotic mutual information between
the signal and the data matrix um in
various uh with various strategies so
some using um
spatial couplings i'm using
interpolation and even others using like
pd's and other techniques
i don't know if that's something but uh
sorry okay now i'm like i'm just a
little confused because uh it's a fair
portion of those papers are not for
linear sparsity in the first
but
they're they're not what sorry for
linear sparsity
they're most of these are polynomially
decaying sparsely so so like end of the
alpha
zero
for n for
i mean there's the one where my name is
showing up too okay then that one we
know okay so it's the one that i could
actually you know know the best but uh
it's for every opponent of sparsely it's
the end of the alpha nonzero okay
yeah but actually others and then
there's some motivary stuff and sos
stuff with
sam and spade and others i think that
also talks about these polynomial
scarcity regimes
okay yeah i i know that some
do and some don't uh you know
uh i
think that the the way that we
characterize the mses and the sharp face
transitions is um novel
oh for sure yeah no i don't mean to take
away from your stuff because i think for
sure there's some new insights in you
like also the sharp estimates that you
get
definitely yeah i i'm like uh totally
willing to admit that trying to
summarize the like
vast landscape of this work is a little
bit challenging for me so it could be
that some of these need to be like
shifted around and
yeah um
uh saying them so
uh
you know so what i will mention is that
you know some of the
the works that i um
am you know uh
confident address um similar problems to
what i'm studying are those those listed
here so in particular the works that i i
know that address um
similar statistical phase transitions in
the sublinear sparsity regimes uh for
binary signals are the ones um listed
here so in particular the first two
works um study sort of a
0 1 phase transition of the minimum mean
square error for a sparse linear
regression problem
that they call an all-or-nothing phase
transition and um
so what i will mention is that uh you
know they they
study something similar in the the um
compressed sensing problem um but they
they use sort of very different
techniques than we do so
uh our
the our work studies the statistical
limits by um
exactly characterizing an asymptotic
mutual information from which the uh
phase transition kind of pops out as a
side effect whereas these guys tackled
the the mmse
um directly and they didn't say anything
about
about the the computational limits
the other works listed um
are related to uh
uh ours and that they study the
sublinear uh sparsity regime
um
for uh models similar uh to or the the
exact same as as we study here but um
in general you know uh
there for for various reasons um
the the work that we give builds on
there so some of these works um give
heuristic uh
locations of the the thresholds um
or not otherwise non-rigorous locations
so they'll um analyze the threshold by
first taking you know into infinity and
then dropping the sparsity to zero which
isn't necessarily the same as having
both of these um
change together
or uh you know they they don't give the
characterize the behavior of the mses um
at
all okay
so um before i present the results i
just wanted to say exactly what i meant
about limits and phase transitions so in
particular the statistical limits and
the phage transitions
address questions like under what
conditions is the information and the
observation sufficient for satisfactory
recovery
um
and we'll say that a phase transition
then occurs if an appropriately
normalized
asymptotic mmse jumps from zero to one
abruptly with changing problem
parameters
um and
how do we actually you know analyze this
this phase um transition
our strategy for studying this is the
the following so the phase transition is
actually going to manifest itself as a
singularity in the mmse so by
singularity i mean a discontinuity in a
first order derivative
and um so we get the the singularity and
the mmse by actually um
looking at the asymptotic mutual
information between the the data and the
spike
and so um
in particular you know we characterize
exactly this asymptotic mutual
information and then we relate it to the
mmse through the so-called immse
relationship which basically says that
the mmse um
is equal to the derivative of the the
mutual information with respect to the
signal-to-noise ratio and so um
therefore if we can get sort of closed
form uh
uh expressions for the mutual
information this gives us closed forms
expressions for the the mmoc from which
we can then find these these phase
transitions
um to study the computational limits uh
we're going to to study an approximate
message passing algorithm or more
specifically the asymptotic performance
of the message passing algorithm
and we'll look for a place where uh you
know that mse jumps from zero to one um
abruptly with changing problem
parameters
and so just a word on on why we're
talking about a and b here
well it turns out that um
approximate message passing is a class
of polynomial time algorithms that um
have been studied
uh for this problem um in the linear
sparsity regime and have shown very
successful results so in particular in
many problem settings um amp provides
bayes optimal signal estimation
and um
it's conjectured that the amp
performance is as good or
better than other polynomial time
algorithms for problems um
of this sort and so by studying the
performance of amp we're going to say
something about the the computational
limits of the
problem
okay
um so this is a summary of which i'll
just skip uh it's just what i just said
but uh we probably don't need it for
this talk
okay so um
what we'd like to do is is um
investigate these um statistical as well
as uh computer computational phase
transition regimes and in particular
we're gonna look at the setting where
the number of non-zeros
in the signal uh vanishes as the the
problem size grows while the snr
diverges to infinity
and so i'll mention that um
you know nontrivial estimation is only
possible in this problem if the snr
grows which
is perhaps not immediately obvious but
here's a quick heuristic justification
it's probably not too hard to convince
yourself that the total snr per non-zero
signal component is like
uh lambda rho
and therefore you know if rho is going
to zero in order for there to be enough
energy to
uh estimate these values at all we need
that that lambda diverges
and so then um kind of the the the
takeaway that that i'll talk about in
this talk is if we look at you know
signals that are bernoulli or bernoulli
rademacher then um the mmse and the mse
of amp
display the zero to one phase
transitions but in fact on widely
different scales so there's a diverging
um
uh computational and statistical gap
okay so um
now to to start presenting the results
um
i first wanted to to discuss the the the
scaling regimes of vanishing spark
sparsity and diverging signal strength
in which we're able to prove
these um
these phase transitions so these are the
regimes where we're able to characterize
these mses exactly
and the for the the statistical phase
transition so the information theoretic
phase transition what we need is that
rho grows
goes to zero more slowly than n to the
negative beta where beta is small enough
and
then we observe a phase transition
for lambda growing like negative log rho
over rho
and the phase transition occurs as a
function of this gamma parameter here
and so uh then the computational uh
phase transition uh
is uh
slightly different so um here for the
copy to prove the the msc of amp for the
computational phase transition we need
rho
uh to to go to zero more slowly than log
n to the negative alpha where alpha's uh
a parameter larger than one and we need
um lambda to grow like uh omega times
uh one over rho squared
and so uh here then the phase transition
occurs as a function of omega yes
so
gamma is what you would call like the
variable in the so-called scaling window
of the transition you're so you're
saying that for any constant gamma
then we're at some continuous value in
the mmsc between zero and one yeah so if
you if you normalize correctly like
gamma equals one is where the phase
transition is so when gamma's larger
than one
uh this is growing um
so easily that you're on the the sort of
uh positive side of the phase transition
but if gamma's less than one you're on
the the bad side of the division oh so
it's not what i said okay thanks
jump suddenly
yeah it jumps from zero to well we'll
see i have some plots to show the way
that the
that it changes
um okay so uh
i will mention that that the work by um
niles weed and um zidique
uh
showed uh the the uh analyzed the
statistical phase transition for this um
problem for a slightly more general
regime so they showed the same critical
point of the transition but they showed
it for general decaying row
however they they didn't characterize
the behavior of the
and so uh we think that perhaps um
you know uh the the the value of the
beta is probably a a weakness of our
proof method but um
uh we're
it's not clear that we can get to the
the general regime that they show
um okay so um
what i want to do is
show a little bit of the behavior of
these phase transitions
with some
simulations so
all the simulations are for the
bernoulli signal but the behavior of the
bernoulli rademacher is is
um the same or similar
and so um here what i've plotted on the
the y-axis is uh
the mutual information
and remember the mutual information is
related to the mmse so this is giving us
information about the statistical phase
transition
along the x-axis i've
uh plotted changing
uh snr
and it's relative to a the critical
point which is given by this
uh negative four negative log rho over
over rho
um
and then the the lines in the plot
correspond to different sparsity levels
so uh we're interested in the sparsity
decreasing so the the you know
uh least sparse signal is the blue curve
and then the most sparse is the the red
curve
uh so the the red curve is like rho it's
like 10 to the negative 20. so we're
very very sparse here and then the as
the the sparsity changes so does the
problem size
so
okay so what we're seeing here right is
kind of in this this limit of
vanishing sparsity what's happening
is as we change the snr
you know um up until a point
right your mutual information between
the signal and the
um
your data increases linearly right so as
you increase the s and r uh you get a a
linear increase in your mutual
information but up until um some
critical point after which you you kind
of get an angular break in the the plot
so that that suggests that you know in
this limit of diverging sparsity um
after you increase the s r beyond that
critical point you don't get any more or
you don't add any more to your your
mutual information
and so then um using the uh imsa i mmse
relationship
uh we can uh translate those results
into results about um the mmse of the
problem so again uh
x-axis is um
increasing uh snr
y-axis is now the mmse for the problem
and the plotted values are decreasing
sparsity with blue is you know the the
the least sparse and red is the the most
stars
and so um
what we're seeing here right is now we
get this sharp
jump
in the mmse as we go to this vanishingly
sparse situation right so uh if we're on
the smaller side of the snr uh of that
threshold then our mmsc is going to take
the value of one which is kind of its
maximum value and on the other side of
this threshold
it jumps down to zero
which is the minimum value
and so um a similar phenomenon occurs
for the ms mse as amp so this is related
to our computational
limits right so again plotted the s and
r on the x-axis but now the critical
value is uh different it's the the
threshold for the amp algorithm
the y-axis is my normalized msc of amp
and i'm still i'm plotting uh decreasing
sparsity so my colors have changed a
little bit here so row is like the least
sparse and um
black is the the most sparse
so as we're we're you know getting more
sparse than this uh sort of sharp zero
one um
uh phase transition shows up again for
the mse of a amp and so i will note that
uh here for the um
the the actual actual constant where the
critical value is
uh we
approximated that numerically but it's
been found in some other works um
uh as well
okay and so um just to as a final plot
here's a look at how what this says
about the the gap between the
computational and the statistical limits
for the problem
so um
here the the
dotted lines are the amp performance or
computational performance the solid
lines are the mmse performance and again
black is the most sparse and uh red here
is the the least sparse and so the
computational
statistical gap is represented by the
the horizontal um sort of distance
between the two lines so you can see
that the the sort of two green lines
here
uh they're closer together than the blue
lines and then the black lines so the
computational statistical gap is
diverging um
as are as we become more sparse and so
um you know in fact right we sort of
characterize at least
uh when when row's growing uh
uh going to zero um
you know slower than log n over negative
alpha this uh gap is determined by the
difference between these these two
critical points
and so uh we'll mention that you know we
think that this gap still holds for the
the sort of uh tighter regime where we
prove the statistical limits but
controlling the amp limits um
was fairly difficult and so we weren't
quite able to get to the the regime that
that we wanted and this is left for for
future work
and so just to wrap up um cindy can i
can i ask the question this is david
yeah it's on the previous slide the the
critical threshold for the statistic for
this
statistical critical threshold is
exactly same
as the one in a proportional regime
where rho n is just a small constant and
and
uh it's a linear proportional regime but
curiously we have a square root there
appearing so i don't know if it's a just
mismatch of the different
parameterization
or
what else but i'm i'm just curious it's
exactly square root of four
log rho n inverse log log rho n and um
uh which but which which it should be
the case except for the square root
shouldn't be there i'm just curious
why why there is a mismatch maybe maybe
you know
um
yeah no off hand i don't
um
different okay elias is saying a
different parameterization i'm trying to
understand
i think yeah it's probably just
uh this right so
oh
okay
that that helps thank you yeah that
helps although although i should
reinforce something that you already
said that in the proportional regime
certainly it would not get all or
nothing behavior will be just a partial
recovery above the statistical threshold
okay
thanks david
spiritual david um
okay uh so to wrap up i will just use
like two minutes to tell you um some
notes on on how we actually do this to
get to kind of the the meat of um
the talk so
um okay so uh for our uh theory we'd
like to show um exact thresholds for
these all or nothing um transitions and
so uh for the statistical limits um
we do this uh
by giving a rigorous derivation of the
the asymptotic mutual information in the
form of a one-dimensional variational
problem
and then um for the computational
results we use a finite sample analysis
of approximate message passing which
rigorously allows us to track its
performance in these these sparse
regimes so in just a little bit more
details
um okay so for the information theoretic
limits uh
the idea is that we use a method called
the adaptive interpolation that um
tells us how to to compute this mutual
information between the signal and the
the spike and it gives us this mutual
information in the form of this one
dimensional uh variational expression
and so um
adaptive interpolation is a method
that's been used to show
these sorts of information theoretic
limits uh
for these sorts of problems and the
linear sparsity regime
in particular by my my co-authors uh
john barbie and
nicola mccree
and um it kind of wasn't obvious uh
a priority that that this could be sort
of um used in this sort of subliner
sparsity regime but um
they they were able to make it work and
so then um once we have this this
variational expression
um this is something we can at least uh
solve for the bernoulli and bernoulli
rademacher
uh signals and then um by
differentiating it um
and making use of the immse relationship
this tells us something about the the
mmse of the problem and so then we get
this
these sorts of close form values of the
mmse um and we can look at their limit
you know as as n goes to infinity
um for the computational results um as
we mentioned we we analyze
appropriate approximate message passing
algorithm for um
the the problem and so a nice feature of
amp is that its performance
is characterized through its state
evolution which is a deterministic um
recursion
and so um
sort of the the the challenge here is
that you know
uh in the setting where row is is a
constant value when it's constant with
respect to n
um then you can use the asymptotic amp
theories or the standard amp theory to
analyze the performance of the algorithm
however when rows changing within you
need sort of a finite sample performance
of the amp
um
oh okay
um
so when rows changing with within you
need um instead sort of a finite sample
analysis of this algorithm that
demonstrates concentration around the
state evolution predictions instead of
like the
uh the the asymptotics um
of the situation and so then once you
have the those concentration arguments
um
you can uh use the state evolution to
characterize this mse performance and
the real sort of technical challenge
here is is you know
when um
i originally studied the concentration
for the amp algorithms i treated you
know a lot of things like it's the state
evolution and um the constants
associated with the the lipschitz
denoisers and the algorithm and so on as
as universal constants with respect to
the problem however here all of these
things now change with n because they
depend on the snr
or the the sparsity and and so you have
to kind of carefully track how all of
these things um
influence the concentration of the amp
algorithm and so once you can kind of
incorporate all of those values all of
those things that change with n now into
the the rates of concentration you can
say something about the msc performance
and so um i'll stop here uh thanks uh
silence
great thanks uh any questions
this time i'm not just stretching
so
uh the number of iterations of amp is
little low of log over log log
and
i guess i'm
well i i this isn't the regime in which
i usually think but i
how many iterations do we really believe
a and b
ought to have i i would have thought it
would be more like
yeah so um i yeah i think you're right
so this is uh
yeah this is something that's haunted me
for a long time now so um the the reason
that we have that statement is because
the t shows up in the rate of
concentration so t being the iteration
number and so in order for like the
the the concentration that we showed to
be you know
non-negligible you know you aren't
bounding probabilities by one um you
need that uh
you know t grows much more slowly than
than n
right um so in some sense the
finite sample version is kind of just a
refined asymptotic statement because it
shows you how all of these things now
grow to end together and so now we've
added some other things like changing
sparsity and stuff that grow within
um in general yeah i mean i think for
any actual like
if you use amp on a real problem uh
you know
login over log login is going to be like
very small so um
you know i'm not sure how much
uh
use those finite sample guarantees are
for like the actual like uh applied
performance of the algorithm
sorry and you you showed results
you should results showing that amp does
achieve
a low mmsc with that small number of
iterations that was one of the graphs
you showed or was that it's eventual
yeah so there
okay so they're when um the row is
really small you need the n
so what we plotted there was actually
the
the
theoretical
performance
of the amp so it wasn't like an
empirical
simulation but
in those situations when row is getting
small n is getting big
right so can i ask something also
possible
do you hear me
yeah go for it yeah um so thanks a lot
by the way for the nice look
so i'm a little bit confused about the
the amp result like you said that it
holds when it's parasitic is at least
one over log to the alpha for some alpha
bigger than one
yes this is what you said
why alpha bigger than one like isn't it
like i'm a little bit confused yeah
like because if right i mean if it's
hard for anything
like um is it a type
no no no no so it could be any alpha
bigger than one i guess is the thing it
just can't
uh
like if it's like then alpha less than
one should work also right because it's
bigger than
so am i missing something so one over
log n is bigger than one over log n
square
right so you can you can pull that that
constant up to make it as quick
with respect to kind of the login
okay as
you want but it can't
be like
uh
i mean eventually
you're never going to get to like
into the negative b even if you increase
that alpha a lot right
yeah no i i'm talking about the other
direction so somehow like i mean i got
to
okay i'm saying probably your result
works for any power of logarithm so if
it's one over log n to some power this
should work because it's uh i don't
understand why i like the power
sure sure yeah yeah so somehow like
it's not that something magically
happens if it's order developed in logan
okay and you said that like you believe
it's probably true if it's uh
below like this but you just didn't have
the you didn't prove it or like would
you good conjecture that they all or
nothing calls for amp even
yeah so we think that we should be able
to get the the same guarantees for the
amp um like in the same regime as the
statistical
uh
guarantees so like you know row grows
more slowly than into the negative beta
but
um
i i haven't been able to like sort it
out yet yeah okay thank you thank you
very much thank you
we have a quick question along the same
sort of lines so first off i mean yeah
really impressive uh results they're so
sharp and so forth um but yeah i'm
curious about the sparsity also maybe
this is the same answer as uh chris's
question on the number of iterations um
but where does this enter are things
just not concentrating enough when you
go to lower sparsities
um
does the state of evolution like if you
say row is i don't know uh
like you know n to the minus one third
or or something like this like where
does this show up in the amp analysis oh
right yeah so
essentially you just you get a
rate of concentration that you know
um
within that rate things like the state
evolution constants or
the lipschitz constants of the denoisers
and stuff all show up and you know that
those things are all related to
lambda and row
and so
if you had you know
uh rho like n to the negative
one third then
you know what you find for that
concentration is that you're kind of
just trivially bounding
it
it's not a small probability anymore
it's a
you know the the probability that the
amp algorithm deviates from its state
evolution is no longer small
you know it's now something like one you
know
so it's just the way that all these
things kind of show up in the the rate
of the the concentration of the amp
around its state evolution
um
okay okay so so there's this um paper of
despondent montanari that you cited and
they they analyzed um i think amp for
atlantic league
i'd be curious i mean because there it's
like you know it's severely sublinear
sparsity it's closer because they get uh
root and sparsity
i might be curious what to revisit that
i forgot the details of what's happening
now have you looked at that can you like
compare what's happening uh
yeah so i can't quite remember the
details
of that um yeah so that one is not
exactly like amp it's actually a moment
yeah
it's a different algorithm right because
it's related to what you guys did as
well right
sorry i just want to clarify that like
in this um yeah that's fundamentally
favorable about planet click so they are
not exactly analyzing amp they're
analyzing
actually more likely propagation
with them so they're using momentum
method to try to compute moments so that
allows them
yeah but but then they also analyze only
the fixed number iteration and then they
use the further spectrum method to
boost the signal in the end i think sure
yeah okay can you have a paper that
extends this to the
piece well yeah yeah so we we kind of
follow that approach and then analyze
that for the sub matrix estimation
problem yeah so we also use the moment
method
but jumping do you do you get estimates
from the nothing aspect in your result
no at that time we are not looking at
all or nothing so but
you don't you didn't have any
understanding of failure of mp below the
threshold of any sort
yeah i don't recall i don't know
but like for example
y'all's paper got the the lambda equals
one over e to the row like they'd
already uh found that threshold so this
is goes back oh oh okay okay now i see
the connections okay yes
okay cool any other questions
uh let's thank cindy again
[Applause]
so i guess that's it for